story where this girl was writing the
tsunami
punai the bathing suit got it sucked up
right into that hole and she had a strap
that was here and it went Bing and it
snapped and it got stuck down did she
Sue N she should have though they were
glad she died cuz she would have
[Music]
won so a couple is suing Disney World
after a woman was given a very powerful
wedgie on a water slide you can what by
a worker yeah like someone just [__]
went you guys ever heard of typhoon
lagon no I I remember is that the
condition you get after a wedgie I
remember the typhoon on a water
ride so there is a there is a um 214 ft
water slide there called Huma
cabanga you got to be kidding dude dead
Ser did mangelo name that according to
Disney people plummet down a near
vertical fivestory drop scary and
writers go without a raft or a tube on
Huma cabanga and you're supposed to be
surprised that you got a wedgie on that
so this woman right is she is she fast
she started to approach speeds of 40 m
hour that's nice and they're told people
people people are told by the way while
you're on it to cross your legs or your
ankles right like in the commercials
however near the end while she's going
down the slide so she's like break
necking it and she's hitting 33 34 35 36
37 38 39 40 mph right and then 16 G's
she feels her body lift up become
airborne and she gets slammed downward
against the slide which uncrossed her
legs at which point the impact of her
sliding into the water sent her bathing
suit up her
[__] a foot and a half upper [__] yeah
dude and so she's coming out of there
and like immediately curls up into a
[__] fetal position while she's in
the water just like you know having her
insides eviscerated by her swimsuit all
the nylon and [__] why does she sue the
swimsuit
company what what do they do why does
she sue her large intestine CU swimsuit
doesn't have a warning on it saying
don't go on humanga
calabanga but so so you did say that she
failed to follow the protocol on how to
ride the she says my legs were forced
apart by break neck speeds bro she's
like no human being should ever have to
go on hum I don't want to be completely
sexist we all know what we're thinking
there's a lot of videos of women riding
rides incorrectly yeah wa keep going
what's your point and that's all I'm
going to
say I remember there was this one video
where a girl was riding down an inner
tube and she didn't hold on she didn't
know to hold that's what she said yeah
she said no told her as soon as they
pushed her she fell off oh my God and
then everyone was like what the [__] why
didn't she hold the inner tube she
commented on her own clip and said I
wasn't told to hold the handles yeah
dude oh Jesus why that's about right I
think that's true don't say that just
say you
slipped don't admit to that or just say
I'm just say I'm stupid yeah just like
driving a car without holding on to the
[__] steering wheel like why it's
kind of funny that like guys be riding
these things wrong also but on purpose
and having a great time loving it have a
blast or when they [__] get an
ultimate WD G they're not suing for it
well yeah it's cuz we have a freaking
prostate Tak a picture with their Bros
on it but that sounds like a good time
to me like it doesn't sound like oh no
the horrors it sounds like yeah you
chose to go down something fast and
crazy and then you're like but she
didn't choose to have like her bathing
suit shoved up her this is a reverse
advertisement for Joe he's like you're
saying you can go 40 m hour with impact
yeah what's the injury that you would
sustain from a bathing suit entering
your what you said [__] Vagas severe
and permanent bodily injury she was
immediately rushed to the hospital and
that's what they found out they had to
they had to surgically remove her
bathing suit from her vagina you got to
be kidding no
way what the
[__] her bathing suit got lodged she
going to make it was all the way up
there yeah it was up there so bad they
had to have four doctors pull it out
C-section dude I'm like how do you like
what's the injury you would get a clip
Burn yeah oh okay she got clip burned
she lubricated from the water get wasn't
enough oh my God that means the vagina
didn't want to let go of The Babys suit
either it's just holding on it was
scared that's vaginal conflict man
vaginal conflict they're suing Disney
for more than $50,000 they're accusing
the company of negligence say Disney
failed to provide her and other riders
with proper protective clothing and
failed to warn them of inherent dangers
I hate these lawsuits cuz it makes it
less fun for the restes it cuz next time
you go it's like you got to wear this
[__] Armor what's the statistic of
people that ride that ride that don't
get hurt versus the people that do get
hurt I think it's 9 95% says 9 she
should lose then if you go to theme
parks outside of America it's way more
fun really yeah because they don't get
sued way more deaths too yeah so then
the things are just crazier the speeds
are crazier everything is like yeah
Mexican theme parks are on another level
yeah sucks for this chick but nah dude
she should she's going to ruin it for
the rest of us yeah no she should suck
it up you know that's why the [__]
grounds are so whack now oh yeah
remember in Australia and you see the
playgrounds they [__] go like three
four stories high and then the parents
just let all the kids climb and ours is
only like they're not very tall everyone
suing over here everything looks like oh
so safe so safe cuz the city gets sued
everybody gets sued [__] all these
people getting injured and sued it's
like duh it's a dangerous thing it's
your fault I mean if they tell you to
not open your legs I mean don't open
your legs would you crazy yeah why would
you open your legs yeah you [__]
horny [__] so they don't even say they
could just say keep your legs crossed
yeah why why wouldn't you keep your legs
crossed in
1994 there was a young girl she was 14
years old and she went on she was at
Disney's Typhoon Lagoon she went on
crush and gusher and they said that her
bathing suit went so far up her body
that she was killed instantly but all of
her bathing suit went up went up her
[__] you mean it just went and it just
got sucked into a [__] I mean the ride
name was crush and gusher oh [__] be
care what's the stats on that be careful
about that one that one has a has a
higher um fatality rate oh have you
heard of uh the one in knots there was
the tsunam there's the tsunami punani
that one was CRA I heard about the story
where this girl was writing the tsunami
punai the bathing suit got [__] it
sucked up right into that [__] hole and
she had a strap that was here and it
went Bing and it snapped and it got
stuck down did she Sue N she should have
though they were glad she died cuz you
would have won yeah but you got a you
straight defamation now it was a giant
cover up it was tire cover that didn't
happen at perilous plunge though dude
really yeah but now we're making it too
real what do you mean when you worked in
knots did you didn't you manage the
water ride you I was I was managing
Bigfoot rapid yeah yeah yeah big rapig
that's one of my favorite you never saw
any [__] injuries [__] injuries were
happening on the [__] daily d
I was guy they had they had to [__]
pay me to sign an NDA too cuz I had to
keep on [__] crying that [__] out
with the jaws of life wow you you the
[__] dis lodger yeah we had a we had a
[__] patent pending for a tool that
we used to [__] crank [__] pend out
why girls so dumb are you seeing chicks
bathing suits just get sucked all the
way up there every day yeah so many
people go to NAS very Farm wearing
bathing suits r with the waterpr that's
so scary have you guys ever been to the
water park at Magic Mountain the one
next to Hurricane Harbor yeah I haven't
been there no I never been to a water
park can we do a I've been ring Waters
Raging Waters I've never been either
ring Waters is dope outside of every kid
[__] [__] and peeing they're
[__] awesome I want to try Typhoon
Lagoon I want to try the crush Crusher
gush crushing
gush you don't want tsunami
punani I to try tsunami punani as a as a
guy right next to perilous [__] later
think they shut down Hurricane Harbor
they did yeah I think so right that's
what n cuz chicks were having to wear
terway bathing
suit what the hell that's what I
heard Soak City is the one that they C
so City that's true I've been to so City
that's a
not sick dude wait was that at
knot I think yeah that's the knot one we
don't have any water park at Disneyland
though here right that's so this is
Disney World yeah Disney World Disney
World yeah I never been in Disney World
have you guys crushing yeah crushing
gusher we should go to hey JK goes to
water park would be
hilarious it's just all I've never been
man also showing up with a bunch of
grown dudes with video cameras is also
weird
as tattoos visible tattoos just having
fun being a couple boys you know we're
just having we're asking the staff Hey
where's tsunami punani it's not on the
map anymore is it still here did you
guys rename it the crushing gusher now
crushing gusher yeah I don't like it
when people complain too much about
their injuries on rides cuz it ruins it
for the rest of us just suck it up dud
it's like just get hurt you're the only
one you're the only one everyone else is
having a good time we're not dumb like
if we get hurt yeah that's our fault you
should award the [__] seat belt you
think she was a little heavy probably
doesn't say if you're going 40 m hour on
a
slide sometimes that's the only times I
wish I was fat cuz when you're doing zip
lines or anything gravity wise like the
bigger you are the quicker you go yeah
there are a lot of like lawsuits with
rides where the person had a body that
was usually not ideal for the seat yeah
yeah yeah that happens a lot but it's
also like you know that was perilous
plunge the lady was top heavy and then
she [__] as the thing was like going
downwards she fell over the oh that's
really how that happened yeah and then
so she fell onto the thing and the thing
rolled over and her [__] kid was next
to her so her kid her kid washed her
[__] and she died why did they let
her ride it cuz they didn't want a fat
shame probably that's why they let that
one kid on remember that one kid that
was on the drop ride fell out they
didn't want to Fat shame him I think
sometimes you have to Fat shame you do
for safety you have to man so you don't
die I mean yeah if it's your life that's
probably the worst way to go out is no
but they'll get sued for fat shaming
dude dude she wanted to go ride a horse
and then they said that there's a 200 lb
limit so she can't and then she was
going all over like oh fat Shamy fat
sham and all the comments were like like
well what about the the poor horse yeah
step on the scale then let's see was did
the horse look extra worried did the
horse afterwards go his knees were
shaking no cuz anyone that's like over
200 something lbs they have to get a
bigger horse prepared for that day
brought the pony out yeah the one that
carries the [__] carries cuz those
are big [__] horses those guys are
huge yeah they got to prepare but then
that they didn't get that full ready
that day uh you got to put inject
steroids into a [__] cdale yeah just
so you don't fast chame somebody you got
to reinforce the cdale dude that's so
funny got to make it have thicker ankles
[__] a horse up to keep the somebody's
emotions okay yeah dud [__] the emo like
don't worry we'll [__] this horse up for
you